okay so the Last of Us episode one is
now out and I'm so excited to talk about
it the first game is my favorite of all
time and I've bought the PS3 version the
PS4 remaster and even the PS5 remake
that released a couple of months ago
this is a game I've completed numerous
times on grounded mode and the series is
something I've been desperate to do a
deep dive on throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the first
episode scene by scene and talking about
all the Easter eggs hidden details and
what they did differently to the game if
you haven't played it then don't worry
because we won't be spoiling what
happens down the line as I want you to
enjoy the twists and turns as much as I
did on my first playthrough however I
may need to touch upon certain things
due to characters that get name dropped
here but I'll only bring them up in our
super spoiler section at the end of the
video which I'll give you a heads up on
I'm nice like that now unlike the game
the series starts off in 1968 originally
we watched as Sarah woke up in her bed
and ventured about the house but here
they do it differently rather than
throwing us in at the night of the
outbreak we get some backstory that
wasn't even filled in in the source
material the game told us very little
about the virus Beyond it being caused
by cordyceps which had mutated to infect
humans these real-life fungi exist in
the jungle and the parasite infects
insects and also anthropods beginning in
1968 though we see a TV show in which
two scientists do a big deal time about
what the biggest threat to humanity is
the first one goes up about how we may
have a pandemic level event that's
caused by a strain of influenza which
awkward now both games were made before
the pandemic and the creative team of
retroactively added this into the show
to comment on it in my opinion the
scientists mentions how airplanes are a
new element that will help viruses like
this spread easier and later on we see
several planes flying overhead as Sarah
Joel and Tommy make their escape they
add a lot of Focus to them during the
truck scene and actually change up how
the crash happens originally it was
caused by another one hitting them but
they do a fake out in the episode and
instead have plain debris causing it now
the sign is played by John Hannah talks
about the threat of cordyceps and how
climate change could allow the fungi to
spread from the more tropical regions of
the world to human population centers he
talks about how cordyceps work and this
is some yet scientists have studied in
the wild the fungi infect their housed
and they then fill them with
hallucinations that caused them to act a
certain way a lot of the time they'll
get ants to climb high up into the trees
and then from here they'll kill the host
and get them to spread their spores one
thing I thought that was so creepy about
the game is that we'd often stumble
across the infected whilst they were
unaware we were in the area you'd often
catch them subbing away in corners and
the creative team said it was horrendous
being one of them due to the parasite
basically infecting your brain similar
to how the Spore ants were set up in
fact it would lay down somewhere and die
and they'd become points of infection
that could fire spores out into the air
we see one of these later on in the
episode but they do stay their hand and
don't reveal the later stages of the
infected in this first entry the
character also says this very important
line snow cures they don't exist it's
not even possible to make them that's
why Ali becomes so important later on
because she seems like the last hoe to
dig Humanity out of this hellhole they
end this speech by clearly setting up
the stakes and showing why the world
ends up the way it does we lose
that's another thing I love about the
game and whereas we normally watch the
outbreak and go from there we get a
massive time gem to see Humanity far far
in the future after this we go to the
title sequence which is presented in a
similar way to the black and white one
that started up the game there's lots of
symbolism here with a fungus rising up
to create a Skyline showing how it's
become the dominant force in the world
you also see one creating a face before
finally settling on the Silhouettes of
Joel and Ellie the theme tune used here
is pulled directly from the game and it
instantly sets the tone of this
solitarian Bleak storyline now if you
enjoyed the video so far it's about to
get a lot better I promise but please
hit the thumbs up button to help us out
also make sure you subscribe as we'll be
covering the show weekly and you
definitely don't want to miss any of our
breakdowns by the way a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into The
Last of Us
[Music]
okay so originally the game took place
in 2013 which just so happened to be the
year of its release we then got the
20-year time Jump like what we have in
the show which took us to the year 2033
the game was littered with calendars
marking the date and in the second one
you could even find a PlayStation 3 with
a copy of Uncharted 2 beside it about
the series changes things up in order to
have the main parts take place in 2023
we start off in 2003 and much like how
the game opens we see things from
Sarah's perspective now originally that
had the player waking up on the night of
the outbreak which also happened to be
Joel's birthday yeah though we get a
full day in the life of Sarah and the
entire time I was wishing I could sit
and watch this with someone who had no
idea about the games and be like does he
know now Sarah is very much a reflection
of Ellie they've even given her a
backpack which wasn't in the game to
make her more closely married to her she
also wears a hurricane drops t-shirt
which Sarah two wore in the game that
had the 2012 Tour whereas this is the O2
one so that it doesn't mess too much
with the timeline neat little Easter egg
on it is that all the locations that
halikin drops to add at are in the order
of places that the characters visit in
the game now we pick up the scene by
starting at Sarah's window and this is
important iconography as an open window
is also summing its used on the game's
menu screen it also ties into something
that we'll talk about in the super
spoiler section and this window's shot
could become something defining down the
line on Sarah's room we see a band
poster for The Clash and also Destiny's
Child this is similar to her room in the
game in which she had a Harkins drop
poster and also one for the in-universe
movie called dawn of the wolf Destiny's
Child poster says Survivor and it's not
this child's Destiny to be a Survivor
too soon too soon now interestingly the
calendar says August but we do get a
confirm later on that the outbreak
happened on September 26th because
that's also Joel's birthday she's just
forgot to change it and I kind of think
this was left like this to show she's
just a Carefree kid or someone on the
set they're getting fired now they also
pick to set it around summer because the
heat would help the spread of the
cordyceps and it adds the idea of the
seasonal storyline that the last of us
has Joel says he's 36 making him 56 when
we join him later and over his left
shoulder we can see a football on the
rack will not say soccer ball your
Chumps and this is actually an important
bit of iconography in the game there's a
photo of Joe and Sarah celebrating her
winning a trophy and the character goes
back and forth over whether to
acknowledge this or not we get a brief
Glimpse at her on the team when we go to
the news report on the radio we can see
a photo of them all together to the
right of it later on when we see Sarah
moving about the house we also get a
good look at the football again
alongside an acoustic guitar on the
other side of the room Charles a keen
guitar player and we learn in the game
that he even wanted to become a singer
at some point in his early life however
he and his wife at Sarah when they were
very young and she ended up leaving him
which is when he took on the
responsibility of raising her now this
point walks in Tommy played by Gabriel
Luna he sounds exactly like Tommy does
in the game and I actually closed my
eyes and couldn't tell the difference
definitely the same if I was having
pancakes they got no clue
but we ain't the only town we know Joel
and Tommy worked his carbon is and
unfortunately due to a job he has to
work a double shift to get stuff
finished for the day at this point of
news report goes out over the radio and
we hear a mention of Jakarta we don't
know where the outbreak originated from
due to the game not really telling us
but it is possible that this is the show
filling in the backstory of how it came
about it's of course a very hot country
and this would tie back to the climate
comments made by the scientist earlier
on Joel's t-shirts inside out and I like
how they have him done in the gray one
that he had at the start of the game
this is reflected in Tommy 2 who's
wearing a salmon I want to say salmon
some ensured like how he does in the
intro now Sarah then goes to Joel's room
and takes his watch out the drawers so
that she can get it fixed in the game
she just bought him but here she's using
his money to get it fixed up because
she's a cheapskate she's a bloody cheap
skate now Joel's watch is extremely
important as it breaks on the night the
infected rise up but he keeps it with
him as a Memento though he shuts himself
off from talking about Sarah there are
points where it can be seen longingly
staring at it as a reminder of what is
Left Behind she also finds a knife in
his drawer hitting at him potentially
having a darker past and outside we see
that the truck has combat veteran on it
and from this it's possible that he
might have been part of Operation Desert
Storm however this could actually belong
to Tommy as well as he's the one driving
it Captain Obvious here but bit of you
don't I think Thomas stuck it in quickly
but Tommy did end up joining the
fireflies when it all went down and his
experience in the Army could have been
the reason why he got so high up in the
ranks Joel says to Marlene later that
she turned his own brother against him
and we might see more of the group from
Tommy's perspective anyway that's enough
it's not in the game so it's not a
spoiler so you better not be [ __ ]
complaining now we also meet their
neighbors at this point and in the game
this is where the first infected attack
from however it wasn't an old lady and
instead it was a man that attacked them
called Jimmy Cooper what's going on
Troopers
something right with them
I think they're sick
[Applause]
picture of George W bush who would have
been president at this time due to him
being in the job from 2001 to 2009. here
we can see the infection has started to
hit Humanity as we can catch a student
twitching away which we later see at the
federal Camp is one of the signs of
infection the cordyceps attached to
someone's brain and affect their nervous
system which is why these little
mannerisms start before it takes control
love the little detail as Sarah steps
off the bus and we can catch an advert
for a Nokia 3310 which I think I've
probably had back in 2003 snake 2
reigning Champion you don't at me anyway
Sarah gets the watch fixed and we start
to see that summing might be off due to
the amount of sirens and the fact the
shop owners close up they're likely
making a run for it like we see people
doing later on and hey I appreciate the
blind thing was a little clock face
Sarah visits her neighbors the adlers
and she asks to borrow the DVDs Curtis
and Viper two this is a film that later
popped up in The Last of Us Part 2
during the conversation has some big
spoilers that kind of Riff on this I'll
say for the super spoiler section and
I'll also go through what was said in
regards to the plot of the movie now
Sarah later gives this to Joel and the
reviews say it's one of the best
performances I've ever seen little
little bit of a Funny Story here that
always makes me chuckle but Jonathan and
Paul Ross both used to be massive movie
critics and they had a bet with each
other about who could get on the back of
the box for Batman Forever they both
wrote really stupid reviews and that's
why the back of the VHS tape for it has
the quote from Jonathan Ross saying one
of the greatest movies ever made Batman
Forever one of the greatest movies ever
made anyway something is clearly off by
the neighbors and the dog is acting
strange too dogs were used by the
bandits to show whether someone had
cordyceps or not as they of course
didn't have the fancy tag that the
federal agents do at this point we get
Jill and Sarah having a conversation on
the sofa which is pulled directly from
the game I think this is
it's nice but I
I think it's stuck it's not what no no
no no
oh ha ha did you what I don't hear
anything
where did you get the money for this
where'd you get the money for this
drugs I sell hardcore drugs drugs
I saw hardcore drugs it's better when I
do I love how they do some of the stuff
about him and the father and daughter
moment is the last real conversation
they have cut to Sarah asleep and this
plays out similar to how it does in the
game only this time they make the pair a
bit closer by having her dude on its lap
in the game I don't think we found out
why Joe left but we did see text on his
phone asking where the hell he was here
we see the phone call was learning that
one of the infected started attacking
people at the bar and Tommy got locked
up for fighting them Joel asked to bail
him out and he put Sarah to bed which is
when we see her waking up which is how
the game properly starts in it you take
control of hair and walk through the
house as you see news reports that are
documenting some of the attacks they
have an explosion happen which then
appears on the news as well whereas here
she's woken up by the sounds of passing
Choppers and dogs the little Pooch
Murphy jumps up at the patio which I
think is playing on the dog we hear
barking that we then hear yelping as
Sarah gets to the door
oh
Sarah visits the adlers and here she
finds that the elderly woman is now up
about and eating people I got a lot of
flashes here to the first zombie that he
come across in Resident Evil with a hair
loss making this appear really similar
we've actually added something to the
infected here and we can see that the
cordyceps comes out of her mouth which
wasn't present in the game in nature
they try and get as high as possible so
they can spread the spores easier and
I'll love this addition to the infected
that makes them more horrifying Shaolin
Tommy arrive with shells swinging a
wrench similar to how you use melee
weapons in the game they jump in the
truck and I love how he can see the
atlas in the street now showing how
quick the infection spreads the truck
ride is really similar to it with it
being word for word at points we also
have them approaching signs for Austin
one way in the hospital which is the
other and this is all ripped right out
of the source material they head towards
the hospital and this is of course where
most of the outbreak would be at its
worst due to people being taken there
after they got sick we learned that the
adlers actually went there to get
medicine for the elderly one and this is
likely how she picked up the infection
in the first place anyway enough of me
talking let's play the scene side by
side so you can see how close they are
some sort of parasite or something Irish
some kind of parasite are we sick no of
course not are we sick no of course not
no cell phone no radio yeah we're doing
great a minute ago newsman wouldn't shut
up cell phone no radio
how do you know
let's lose this Farm
I hope that some [ __ ] made it out
it's Jimmy's Place
we're good didn't Jimmy work in the city
kids so do we
I'm driving who do you think you're
doing keep driving I got a Kid Joe so do
we we have room
hey someone else will come along
[ __ ] everybody had the same [ __ ] idea
everyone and their mother had the same
damn idea
come on people move what are they
running from
I'm trying oh no
after the truck's thrown off the road
Sarah's unable to walk and Joel has to
carry her this is where we take control
of him in the game and it leads to them
running through a restaurant chased by
the infected like what we see here at
this point we'll get what's probably the
most devastating part in the whole story
normally in post-apocalyptic Tales When
characters run into soldiers it's often
a sign of safety they used as a way to
show other people of someone looking
after them but here it's the complete
opposite order to shoot Joel and Sarah
he fires upon them and this ends up
killing Sarah now watch this scene a ton
of times in the game and it was only
upon this watch shoe that I realized
that they did this because Cyril was
injured and they might have suspected a
bite anyway it completely rips your
heart out and as always I'm gonna show
you how it works alongside the game
foreign
oh no
[Music]
sir
[Music]
move your hands babe
okay I know baby I know
oh my God
you're gonna be okay baby stay with me
I know I know I know I know I know it
hurts
[Music]
baby baby listen to me I gotta get you
up
come on baby please I know baby I know
Sarah
[Music]
come on baby girl I gotta get you
baby
[Music]
don't do this to me
come on come on come on baby
come on completely gut wrenching and
it's the defining mom and Joel's life
that changes him for the worse the scene
is the key to understanding the
character and it sets up basically
everything that's to come so from here
we get a time Jump of 20 years and a big
section that wasn't in the game here we
watch a child out in the wilderness
making their way to the federal Camp
which is located in Boston the red shirt
reminded me a lot of the girl in
Schindler's List that we see moving
through the devastation and later on her
body's cast aside similar to what we see
Joel doing his role is also very similar
to some characters in the stand with
there being Body Disposal Crews that had
to get rid of the dead after the world
had destabilized this child's found to
be infected and the federal soldiers end
up euthanizing them fedra is basically
the remnants of the federal government
but they were seen as fascist in The
Last of Us Universe they had strict
rules that sends people to death for
very very little and in the game were
first introduced to them forcing people
to their knees and shooting the infected
now because of their strict rule many
resistance groups rose up including the
fireflies several Rebels rose up and
they propped up their own leaders which
if they were better or not is another
question entirely now I think yeah
they're painted out in a better light
and though they kill the kid they do it
mercifully and even lie to make it seem
like they're gonna be taking care of
them now what's very Bleak about the
last of us is that there's barely any
kids in the entire thing most of the
people we follow are middle aged and as
they say children are our future the
fact there's so few kids shows how
doomed humanity is and Ellie represents
not only the hope and the Cure but also
in the fact that children can make it in
this world even though the two we meet
early on here are killed but moving on
and we also see a poster that breaks
down the full time to infection and we
can see that Ellie's bite would be
roughly two to eight hours as with one
being on the [ __ ] giving someone a day
ones in the neck and face give someone 5
to 15 minutes which explains why the
atlas got up so quickly in the truck
scene the kids killed after the scanner
flashes red on them and this very much
foreshadows the Fate that would have
come to Ellie had Joe not saved her life
it's heartbreaking because we don't
really know what the Red symbol means
and part of me was hoping that the kid
made it out after the guard said you're
safe sadly though we see her body in the
back of a truck and this is how I
reintroduced to Joel and where he is now
carries the body almost like how he did
with Sarah and dumps him on the fire
showing no attachment at all at this
point we see ration cards being handed
out he's also appeared in the game and
they look identical to how they did in
that we thank good shots of the city and
also get a careful sign this pops up in
the game as well and it's identical to
the one you see when you first walk
around Boston we see some of the
citizens and kachigan and Al Gore
Lieberman campaign share from the 2000s
election campaign don't know why he's
wearing this but they could possibly be
reminiscent thing about a world in which
Gore was in charge because because of
all of his climate change stuff or they
might be the only clothes they've been
able to get a hold of in the last 20
years Firefly symbols are covered up
because they could cause dissent and we
see how people are hang for leaving the
QC this is something at Joe does
regularly and he works as a Smuggler we
catch a federal Soldier twitching but
it's not because it's infected and Jill
in fact ends up selling him pills in the
game this is something that Tess is
coming back from when we first meet it
so I'll take one guess the uh whole deal
went South and the client made off with
our pills is that about right the guard
shows up later on when he catches them
outside and I love this addition to the
series for when he pops back up we
pretty much don't spend any time with
regards Beyond chucking them out in the
game and it shows how they're all
working in Shades of Gray without
wanting people to exit the qz whilst
also killing those that do he then
brings up the Firefly Attacks and these
end up bringing tests from her captives
we see a big bit of graffiti for the
fireflies on the wall and this is
similar to the radio messages that
Marlene was putting out in the game
remember when you're lost in the
darkness walk for the light
from here we jump to test in a moment
that we weren't really privy to in the
game in that we start with y'all waking
up and she shows up to the apartment
beaten up after two people were sent
after her by Robert it turned out that
Jill and Tess had sold them some guns
that the fireflies also got here though
it all centers around the truck battery
I actually prefer it with a battery
being something they can use to get a
car to get out of there and it kind of
ties back to the the backstory with
Tommy Now They do change things up from
the game and the first part in the
future follows Joel and Tess as they
hunt Robert down eventually they catch
and kill him which is when Marlene
arrives and it's this that leads into
the early mission interestingly
Marlene's played by Mill Dandridge who
just so also happened to play her in the
game now here we pick up with test tied
up and Robert begging her to let things
go it shows how much of a g she is and
in the game she killed the captors
herself the Firefly explosion allows her
to escape and this is riffing on the
scene in the game when they got across a
checkpoint and one blows off which makes
Tess and Joe flee through the tunnels
and from here we jump to Ellie chained
up she's currently being observed due to
being bit and we see her standing in
front of a window again calling back to
that iconography naughty dog have added
in their own Uncharted Easter egg and
Ellie's wearing the same shirt that
Young Nathan Drake had on in Uncharted
3. Joel goes to a radio operator and we
learned that he's been trying to reach
out to Tommy which is what the truck
batteries for he returned to the
apartment and Falls to sleep on the bed
hearing Echoes of his brother screaming
Joel Tommy and Tess had to do horrendous
things in order to survive and we might
even get the backstory filled in beyond
what we got in the game curtisel waking
up which is where we pick up after the
time Jump and we see Tess telling him
about Robert in a scene that Echoes how
we first meet it they man up and decide
to head out which is when we cut to
Marlene leader of the fireflies we then
see them planning attacks with a map on
the table if forces are starting to ask
questions about why people are dying and
why there's a random girl locked up just
down the hall Marlene is wearing clothes
similar to the game and they're planning
to move every Firefly out of the city
because of Ellie's immunity we even see
one try trying to recruit Joel and I
love how the fireflies are slotted in
almost every aspect of the city also
worth pointing out that Tess is wearing
the exact same clothes that she hasn't
in the game except for the bandana which
uh I like that banana now when Joel
stands against the wall we can also see
several posters including one in the
bottom left for Curtis Viper two at this
point Marlene goes to Ali and she throws
her bag over this is exactly the same as
the game and it even has the little
Cyclops head like what the character has
in that you also see her pull out a
Fleck knife which is something that she
uses throughout the original work Molly
and gives her the keys to her handcuffs
and she brings up the Federal military
school future spoilers that will not
spoil now but we will talk about them
later on in the video and how this ties
in a parts of the story coming up now
it's sort of touched upon here but
Marlene Hadley drafted into a fedra
program as a child and this was to keep
it safe she knew her mother and wanted
her away from the fireflies and also
brings up Riley which we'll save that
for later on anyway she warns Ellie that
she'll be killed if people know about
her and this this comes to be true Jill
and Tess make their way through some
buildings and they move underground
which is a similar thing to what they
did in the game now they come across an
infected person who's grown into the
wall and I absolutely love the look of
this as it hits towards the more mutated
ones that appear later on everything is
spot on here including the green wall
which looks like it's ripped right out
of the PlayStation classic but moving
through the tunnels you encounter
someone stuck to a wall and I was kind
of hoping they'd pull out the gas masks
for this bit but unfortunately they
don't and those stuck into the wall
would attach and then fire sport in the
environment but sadly they cut that out
here anyway it leads them to the Firefly
base which is where they find Robert
dead in the game it was Tess who shot
him but either way he gets capped in the
same place at this point they come
across a wounded Marlene similar The
Source material and Ellie attempts to
attack Joel which is how she's first
introduced in the original work Jolin
tests attached with transporting Ellie
to a bunch of fireflies and in exchange
they'll be given a whole truck they
agree Ali we get a scene in which they
rest up in a room whilst the rain Pours
Down this is similar to how it played
out in the original with him all laying
low here for the first time and Joel
getting some should I Ellie finds a note
detailing codewords and throughout the
game you'd often come across notes with
crude scribblings in them detailing
things like safe codes backstories and
information about the groups you
encounter this is inside a billboard
Burke and it details how songs from each
decade detail whether there's a new
stocking are the 80s have a big X next
to them and we learn that this means
danger this is very important as come
the end of the episode we hear a song
detailing the danger that they're
heading into we can see that the pages
open on the 1970s and at the top you can
catch the Long and Winding Road slash
For You Blue released by The Beatles
this single had for you blue is the
B-side to it and the long and Winding
Road could be a little nod to the big
journey ahead of them big reach but yeah
it's been left behind by Bill and Frank
who will talk about more in the spoiler
section I've been teasing agile falls
asleep and we get get some repeated
lines from the game
you Mumble on your sleep
you mumble in your sleep now that night
they sneak through the streets and I
remember playing this and it being so
intense as the trucks moved past and
spotlights rain down outside the wall
you sneak underground and then pop up
like what we see here and have to avoid
search lights as they pierce the
surroundings love the juxtaposition of a
big sign that says welcome which is of
course something that the Shadows of the
federal soldiers completely go against
we then get this line from Ellie
holy [ __ ]
I'm actually outside
holy [ __ ] I'm actually outside and they
also sneak through a pipe which is a lot
like the sewer ones that you ended up
crawling through at this point they come
across the soldier whereas in the
original they were caught by two in the
game Ali attacked them upon being
scanned and Joel and Tess jumped and
shot them respectively here though he
gets a PTSD flashback of Sarah's death
which triggers him into attacking
actually think this works better
especially with a soldier returning and
it shows that Gerald's even willing to
attack people they know if it rubs him
the wrong way the Disco Rally's biting
she says
this is three weeks old nobody lasts
more than a day it's three weeks old you
know everyone turns within two days so
you stop bullshitting it's three weeks
the alarm rings and the group head
through the fence which is when we cut
to the radio to hear the song never let
me down again by Depeche Mode it
contains lyrics like I'm taking a ride
with my best friend sort of playing into
the show now this signals the incoming
danger as we watch the group head to the
twin skyscrapers from the game over the
top of this we hear the Cry of and
infected and we end the episode with a
lingering shot on them now we've hit
that long-awaited super spoiler section
and from this point on we'll be covering
things from both games so if you haven't
played them then thanks for sticking
with me I'll see you next week you
better be back mate you you promised you
would anyway yeah spoilers just just
wait for everyone to leave right okay
they're gone now the first point is
Joel's guitar that we see in the
beginning of the episode this is how the
second game opens with him strumming
away on it it's also had the second game
ends with Ellie playing on it too but
she's unable to properly do it due to
Hell losing her fingers we also get a
lingering shot of the window to close
the game out which is very reminiscent
of how the scene with Sarah opens which
of course ties in with the menu now in
the episode there's of course the
mention of Riley as well didn't want to
spoil it for those that didn't know but
here now so you either play the game or
you don't care and this was the girl
that was with Ellie on the night that
she got bit this is all chronicled in
the Left Behind DLC which is basically a
night in which Riley takes Ellie to the
mall before she shipped off with the
fireflies the parent of kissing and
Riley agrees to stay but the piece is
interrupted by the infected who end up
swarming the area Riley dies and Ellie
of course survives which he carries a
lot of guilt over now early on in the
episode the sinus talks about how the
fungus devours its house from the inside
and where we look at the clickers we can
see the entire top part of their head
has been replaced by the fungi the
scientist also explains how do the fungi
being something we use for penicillin
that it can maintain a host for a
prolonged period of time in the game
we've caused meet the infected decades
down the line and we can see just how
far they mutate aid and there's also the
mention of a radio tower in the episode
which is where I'm guessing they'll head
to after they meet Henry and Sam this
was the location they camped out at and
it's probably going to be somewhere that
appears later on the series along with
all the Riley stuff not really an Easter
egg but Sarah's played by Nico Parker
who's also the daughter of danry Newton
also the showrunners have said there's
gonna be no spores or gas masks in the
series Neil druckman said it's because
if there were Sports in this world they
would spread everywhere and everyone
would have to wear masks all the time
that kind of sucks as I love the
aesthetic they brought in the game and I
I think people could have suspended
their disbelief or probably not have
even had that cross their mind because
we're living in a world of zombie fungi
to me it would have given the infected
encounters a sort of upside down from
stranger things feel but alas tis no
more now as for Curtis and Viper 2 this
is the movie that Joel and Sarah were
gonna watch together the night that she
died he never got to see it and in a
bitter Twist of irony it's also the
movie that giola gonna watch the night
that he died too Joel and Ellie had had
her falling out due to her discovering
the truth but she had decided to see if
she could forgive him by inviting him
over to watch a movie that night they
were gonna watch it and here's what
Ellie had to say what movie you guys
gonna watch what's Joel into
uh Curtis and Viper too that's the one
that's been on my radar for a while oh
wow
we used to watch these cheesy 80s action
movies
he's really into them oh no
I actually really like them too
what's Curtis and Viper 2 about
okay so two former Commandos that go
Rogue to fight bad guys and I think in
this one they go up against Russian
spies or something
I'm more interested in this than I
thought I would be all right so the
young one Viper he's a trained ninja and
he's a complete badass
so how old is he in the first movie
uh 10.
wait how many movies did they make of
this
uh I think they made four
jeez
Joel actually saw the last one on the
theater
am I crazy
yes
lastly is Bill and Frank the former of
which we know will be played by Nick
Offerman he's someone Jill and Tess have
had a long-standing relationship with
and upon reaching him Gio and Elli are
escorted to a school in order to get a
car battery so don't get it but they do
find Frank who discovered was bit and he
unalived himself which I have to say
because YouTube's been ridiculously
strict with the demonetization recently
a pair were lovers but they grew apart
and Frank fled in order to get away from
him anyway I think that's all his
spoilery strikes too and I really hope
that you enjoyed the breakdown I had a
blast putting this together and I'm so
glad that HBO have done Justice to the
game I was worried they might mess it up
and though it's very it's very very
early days I think this first episode
was great really captures the feel of
the source material and as a fan I
couldn't have asked for more obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
whether you agree or not but for me yeah
this was a great way to start the series
now if you want something else to watch
and you don't mind Last of Us spoilers
then definitely check out our Brighton
and why the game's got the effect ending
it talks about all the themes in it some
things you might have missed and if you
enjoyed this breakdown then you're gonna
love that too hopefully see you over
there and yeah make sure you stick with
us as we're going to be doing last of us
every single week we're going to be
milking it dry and yeah I hope you come
along for the ride by the way thanks for
clicking this I'll be bored I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]